an unexpected and Troublesome feature of
being human is that we feel so much more
than we spontaneously realize we feel
there are emotions coursing through US
of anger or Joy resentment or fear that
lie just outside the sphere of ordinary
Consciousness and that elude us as we
rush through the challenges of Our Lives
these emotions lie low in part because
they're often too shocking or sad or
contrary to expectations for us to want
to make sense of them we might hate
where we're supposed to love or might
feel sad where we are meant to be
practical and so out of timidity and
fear we omit to register our authentic
reality
or else our feelings get ignored because
they enter our minds too fast and in too
great a quantity for us to disentangle
them in the limited time we devote to
self-understanding
and yet unless the full panoply of our
emotions is regularly identified and
adequately felt we are likely to fall
prey to arrange a psychological ills
anxiety paranoia depression and worse
mental unwellness is borne out of an
accumulation of unfelt feelings
we must do ourselves the favor of
regularly ideally once a day carving out
periods in which to get more deeply
acquainted with our true emotions
we must continually ask ourselves a
simple sounding but Grand and deep
question what am I feeling now
to draw out valuable answers we should
sit somewhere quiet probably in bed with
the lights low and a pad and Pen handy
we should close our eyes and let the
generosity and free-form nature of the
question resonate
after a few moments of scanning the
penumbra of the inner mind we're liable
to pick up a few intimations of
something it might be the rustle of a
disturbingly well camouflaged anxiety
with some of the stealth of a hunter in
the undergrowth or a fisherman by the
bank of a river we can press ourselves
to reflect further
what does it seem we are actually
anxious about
it may require a good deal more reverie
and inner inquiry before we very
gradually feel a recognizable notion
emerging like a landscape subtly
appearing at the slow break of a summer
day
we may need to decode apparently minute
moments of aggression meanness confusion
or grief that have impacted on us
without us properly noticing or we might
as we examine ourselves detect traces of
ancient traumas that seem to be still
active in distant valleys someone is
crying someone is very worried a small
person who might be us needs our help
quite badly
we should carry out a similar process
with our bodies where many more muted
feelings lie buried what's my body
feeling we can ask strangely but
usefully what would it like to talk to
me about if only it could
and to get more specific if my shoulders
could speak right now what might they
say and my chest what would it say and
my arms my hands my legs my feet our
limbs might want to curl into a ball and
long for reassurance or else hit an
opponent or elongate themselves
defiantly and boldly or they might
remember an old frustrated wish to be
held tightly on a comforting chest
through 10 or 20 minutes of this kind of
concentrated but Loose and exploratory
wander through ourselves we reduce the
worry and sorrow of unfelt feelings we
become sad where we were previously
Melancholy angry where we were irritable
and compassionate where we were anxious
and the result is a newfound peace of
mind and likeness of the Soul
we seem to have so much time for
everything
except for what can save us